Tennyson tell us about your characters
more notably the female characters in
your current IndieGoGo campaign for you
want a theory off camera we've been
talking a little bit about how um it's
really hard to find great female
characters particularly in genre cinema
but I ain't film in general and and one
of the things I love the most about
working on the star my record was
working with Danielle working with our
female cast members and I really wanted
to make a movie that created a positive
a positive female archetype in genre
cinema you know you look at the most
compelling leading female roles in film
in genre for the last 20 years have all
been a response to Ellen Ripley an alien
she's got great conflict she's a very
strong woman but at its core alien is a
body horror story about things leaping
out of your body and killing everybody
it's it's got motherhood issues and um
when you get right down to it you even
look at characters like Buffy the
Vampire they're out to commit genocide
which is a good thing in the movie
because vampires are really dangerous
you know but or the show but um I wanted
to tell a story about women who were
becoming healthier through their
experiences so so quantum theory at its
core is about these two best friends who
have gone through college together and
have become they're geniuses they can
relate to each other and they can't
relate to that many other people they
have an amazing relationship they
challenge each other they push each
other they create this technology that
lets them literally change reality
itself restructure the universe and it
is taken from them by a defense
contractor headed by the most
unscrupulous well-heeled intelligent
sophisticated far thinking individual
you can possibly imagine a man who has
long outlived his need to make mistakes
he's playing God he's doing it with eyes
wide open and he changes reality on them
and they wake up one day and they're
working for him building their
technology and no one in the world even
knows it ever belonged to them yes
you